hello and welcome to the Star Wars
Outlaws official gameplay walkthrough
breakdown I'm Chasity vicencio with
Ubisoft news and I'm joined by narrative
director nabib khabari creative director
Julian Garrity and game director
Matthias Carlson who are going to give
us more information about what we saw in
the gameplay walkthrough
here we go
this is our first ever introduction to
Nyx NYX is a Merkel a rare and exotic
creature whose home planet Still Remains
a mystery he's got a very curious
personality as you can see here you can
be a bit stubborn but he has an
incredibly strong bond with K and always
follows her lead she's grown up with the
Knicks for most of her life he's not
just a pet he's a family
good boy and here we have okay first
introduction to a brand new scoundrel in
this galaxy
K is a young Thief who's found herself
on the moon of Tashara which is a hive
of Underworld activity she's picked up a
high-risk job to steal a Priceless sort
of mollusk-like object from a lieutenant
of the pike Syndicate once she's grabbed
it with the help of Nick she's going to
turn it in and earn some much needed
credits
so Pikes are one of the syndicates that
we'll be tangling with in uh Star Wars
Outlaws and the Pikes here are borrowing
without permission some vehicles from
the Empire and the rebels and different
people and cutting them up next
is uh more than just a lovable and
fierce companion and next is a whole bag
of tricks in and of himself
saw him push that button from a distance
he can distract guards he can attack on
command he can help you with puzzles he
can help you discover Secrets as well he
is very much conceived as a symbiotic
part of the player's control over K and
Nick so we're really thinking of them
together as a whole
I was just leaving
so we're mid K in the beginning of the
game she knows her way around the
Blaster it's not necessarily her first
option or primary tool to solve a solid
problem or situation however as we
progress through the game and it's many
ever more dangerous situation both K and
the Blaster itself will evolve and
improve and you will soon find it to be
Central and very versatile tool
for more than just directly taking out
them okay okay we'll figure this out
case Blaster is very meaningful to her
and this Blaster has a lot of modules
that you can discover upgrade and apply
to the Blaster that allow you to deal
with situations in radically different
ways
hey Nick
so here I think we have a very good
example of the type of role Nix can play
even in something like a bull on fire
fight where that enemy that we took out
dropped the gun that he was just about
to shoot you with Knicks can you know
slink down and retrieve that weapon for
you
sometimes best solution is just to get
out of there
so ever since we kicked off this project
uh in collaboration with lucasfilm games
one of the things that they were
passionate about of course is
authenticity one of the things we were
passionate about is bringing something
to the Galaxy of Star Wars and one of
the biggest things was this Moon Tushar
and Tashara we developed uh working very
closely with lucasfilm everything from
its vegetation to the wildlife to its
deep rich culture and all of the
activities that we can discover during
this trailer and even more
one of the key pillars for both K the
character and or the the core gameplay
in general in Taurus Atlas is what we
call a resourceful Underdog K is a
capable and daring person and we reflect
that
in gameplay with you having access to a
wide range of actions and abilities ever
growing of course as you play for the
game ranging from stealth to full on
fire fights so as we still saw here uh
you know shooting from you know driving
your speed room Full Speed Ahead under a
fire from enemies we said if we can make
the player think like oh I can't believe
I made it when when the years play
through something it's a success
comforting
Kay's reputation with the syndicates
will play a big role in how she
approaches her journey whether it's the
Pikes Huts or others we had a saying
that in the Underworld you live and die
by your reputation if a job she takes
hurts to Syndicate those opportunities
aren't available so her choices play
into how she experiences
there's Johnson's hope this is Johnson's
hope Johnson's hope is one of the
settlements that we have in the game so
this is a tiny outcrop an oasis of
civilization in these Windswept planes
and it usually contains a drinking hole
Cantina and these are hubs of activity
too so we very much enjoyed developing
how it would look and feel and what sort
of vibe that Cantina would have
but this is just one of many settlements
and cities that cable discover across
the Galaxy and that includes the capital
of maragana a city on Tashara filled
with corruption and underworld activity
no
okay Andy five is a BX Commando built by
the separatists and battle hardened
during the Clone Wars nowadays though he
serves as kind of an enforcer Droid in
the Underworld he's partnered with K as
they attempt to pull off a big high-risk
job it's the opportunity of a lifetime
friend
you can't be trusted
who can out here
see you back at the ship
so various jobs and favors for the the
different characters and factions you
encounter they play an important role in
everything from learning new things
actually unlocking equipment and
abilities to managing your precious
reputation in the Underworld which is
the key to some of the most lucrative
opportunities out there important note
though something that's key to the
fantasy of the free scoundrel lifestyle
is that you're never in servitude of
everyone you're making your own choices
carving your own path through this world
making a name for yourself job was more
complicated than you said Danka
you lived
if he works for whether it's with
syndicates or otherwise is crucial to
creating a reputation for herself and
then how she approaches those syndicates
through those choices is going to be key
to getting bigger and better rewards
whether it's for credits or Priceless
artifacts
so nothing in the Underworld is black
and white and we wanted to reflect that
in the choices she makes when taking on
jobs this is one example of many does
she just hand over what was stolen keep
a cut for herself lie about how the job
went down or the Intel she learned it's
really left up to her in these scenes
where we're gonna give a choice to the
player and these choices that there is
no wrong onset there's just ways to
weave Your Own Story ways to change
challenge increase your reputation with
certain factions and syndicates decrease
it gain an advantage or a different
perspective on the story too so we put a
lot of effort in giving the player
agency over their own trajectory
so the game takes place in the original
trilogy era so the Empire is at the
height of its power outage so they're
always looming there somewhere in the
background ever watchful but as you can
see here we want to show a different
side to the Empire and how it intersects
with the underworld and that means
corruption particularly on Tashara even
though it's Imperial run the local
Governors and officers lean into
corruption and have worked out special
arrangements with the syndicates that
benefit them
so this is The Wanted system and The
Wanted system uh is something that's
gonna be ever present within the game if
you are you a quartz or challenge the
Empire you're gonna start to get wanted
and if you continue you persist and you
do even more actions that wanted level's
just gonna go up
at the highest levels the Empire will
throw a huge amount of resistance and
forces in your way so that's something
that you can play around with but you're
best of trying to avoid as much as
possible very important for us in this
experience is that there will always be
some way for you to de-escalate or
Escape
oh this is uh the Trailblazer now if
there's one dream that a lot of game
developers have it's the help design a
spaceship for Star Wars this is our take
on that the Trailblazer
the Trailblazer is an EML 850 light
freighter from the Republic era but to K
this is home and if you're a scoundrel
traveling throughout the Galaxy the
first thing you need is a ship and for K
there's none better than the Trailblazer
so now we're in space and you know one
of the things that was very precious to
us is having this seamless experience of
going on foot to your speeder to uh your
spaceship out of the atmosphere and into
space and space is a dangerous place but
it's a place full of opportunities too
so we'll be using it for combat both on
a an intimate dog fighting level an epic
level with bigger ships but also for
Discovery exploration and special
surprises
[Music]
it's important to hit those classic
iconic notes of Star Wars so remind
players of the era that they're playing
in and the fact that the Galaxy is
something that is wide diverse but
iconic at the same time one of the
things that is important for us is that
every planet that you will visit in this
adventure has a distinct profile not
just a very bespoke story uh but also
Wildlife an ecosystem and situations
that really radically change from
location to location and space is just
another part of that so we're trying to
develop distinct profiles for every
single orbital region
foreign
from the start when we sat down thinking
about this game that we wanted to offer
that full seamless experience you know
sitting in the Cantina in a city on a
planet surface jumping on your own
speeder driving to euron ship and as we
just saw seamlessly flying into space is
something that we're incredibly pleased
and happy and excited that we're able to
to actually offer
we really enjoyed making this and we
can't wait for you to experience a new
Star Wars Adventure
[Music]